previously on young Sheldon who are you
that page a unique child can require a
lot of attention try all the attention
this is oddly reminiscent of a dinner
with my family do you think stone-age
parents stayed together forever they
have to there were no lawyers letting my
parents are getting a divorce why they
fight all the time about what mostly me
I guess I'm lucky why I'm the glue that
holds our family together I just sat
down but you're finished fog George if I
wanted to make a cup of coffee
out-of-state in my house that's fine by
then I won't know who you are anyway
guess who was getting a divorce
about time Congrats Linda and Barry
Swanson
who's that and can you tell me why you
make coffee there Paige's parents who
the little smart girl
apparently she's taken a divorce really
hard
I guess she's been having trouble in
school oh poor thing
Linda thinks Sheldon might be a good
influence you know maybe rub off on her
a little bit what she wants her kid to
be more like Sheldon oh good news Paige
is gonna spend the weekend with us my
history with Paige brought up
complicated feelings
you know if he'll be doing a full-color
Arctic calculation with matrix
manipulations I know you're in my spot
she disturbed me enraged me
checkmate things were simpler for my
simple-minded sister yay
[Music]